so under the heading of theoretical
versus experimental probability that's
actually kind of important thing we are
comparing these ideas cuz they're not
the same
let's think about theoretical probably
you'll have um you'll have diced they're
okay so we write it like this we say e
is whatever event you're interested
for instance what were you rolling
before on six is Right probability of a
six okay
so the way you work out a probability of
an event the probability of a six is now
see if you remember we did covered this
before what's the fraction in words what
is it okay so the number in that case
the probability of six would be 1 over 6
but where do we get the 1 of the 6 from
wide it's not good wait hold on
so that's the that's the genomic thats
the 6 there's 1 2 3 4 5 6
those are the possible outcomes right
which also has a fancy a technical name
that'll start some it starts with an
answer that's a bonus it's not a - this
is actually sample splits very good i
care on the ball right so this is also
known as sample space right so you could
list out the sample space it's 1 2 3 4 5
6 ok it's possible outcomes on the
denominator and then on the numerator up
and 1 where does that come from well
it's it's what we're interested in right
like how many sixes are there on the die
and the answer is this one 6 ok so the
way they usually state is is favorable
outcomes it's plural because well there
might be more than one way depending on
what you're asking
we might not want the probability of 6
we might say what's the probability of
rolling an even number and the answer
would be
it'll be 1/2 because there are 3 ways to
get even numbers 2 4 6 over 6 which is
uh-huh
ok so this is for the this is good right
now the way experimental probability
works is well what happens if you
actually do it and what happens in
practice okay and it's off by a little
bit it's off by a little bit so it's the
same idea of a fraction right but it is
I'm gonna write the Saturn form right
how many times well what's the free
see of the favorable outcome so I
actually want to record I might tally
off right how many times I get it over
not possible outcomes but how many times
do I experiment how many times do I roll
the die right how many experiments now
this is important this difference
between these two right because of it in
theory right theoretical probability for
something like say rolling a six is
always the same I mean assuming it's
fair right it should always be a six but
the experimental probability will change
let's try this for instance I'm gonna
roll the dice right and you can roll it
on women you'll get different results
obviously now I roll it first and I've
got no one okay so in the first case if
you've got the probability of a seat
okay the first thing I get is how many
times have I gotten a six not a trick
question
none right so it's zero right and then
how many experiments are done and top
one so at the moment that's the
experimental probability zero percent
well why is this a problem why did I get
zero percent when we know it shouldn't
be how would I improve this do it again
a roll again okay so oh I've got a six
okay so now it's I got once and my
eternal recurrence is 250 percent that's
not what I was expecting either but if I
keep on going right and you can do this
as many times as you like
no - so now I'm - sorry
one out of three that's what you won't
like it and if I keep going right I'm
gonna get different experimental
polities all the way what you would hope
is that if you do this many many times
and starts to approach this theoretical
probability does that make sense okay so
the important thing is to get this is
like figure it in an ideal situation a
perfect situation if you like
and this is what what actually happens